and
of course eddie hearn is already
preparing his ex dude he's preparing it
yeah that's what he does he's a he's a
weasel he's a snake
snake guy right there okay go in on this
it's like
this seems like a good clip
[Laughter]
we're getting the title already
this is good for youtube yeah yeah
yeah what do you mean he's a wee lips
hey guys
i'm in the flagrant grip
uh
man i don't even know where to begin
with him but he's uh
he's very two-faced
you know i think off-camera he's like on
your side like man you do i love what
you're doing actually and like i really
respect it and blah blah blah and you're
going to take this a long way and then
the cameras come on and he's like you're
not that good
saying so he's selling he's like a
backhand it's like a backhanded
compliment yeah but or a backhanded diss
like the the the way he words it and
[ __ ] he's like oh you're average well
average isn't that bad well
eddie what if i called your wife average
you know what i'm saying like that
then
you know what i'm saying so yeah yeah um
jake paul
he just is a bullshitter you know he
gets paid to just [ __ ] talk yeah
that's that's all he does and so he's
just pulling words out of his ass half
the time i mean he inherited his dad's
company
who was his dad uh barry hearn
i believe and just inherited his dad's
company like you know typical rich kid
growing up
here's the company son like never had to
work for anything and so he doesn't
actually understand what it's like to be
a fighter um to
fight through adversity and i just like
see that and he the fact that he
just
loves to
belittle people in that sense and act
like he knows it all
just wanna
i think you knew where to begin buddy